I'm fully in the camp of C++ is not a strongly typed language. And we jump through a lot of hoops to try to make it more strongly typed. We write strongly typed wrappers. We delete problematic overloads. We write templates that are constrained in specific ways. We say, I mean, like we teach single parameter or variadic constructors or constructors with default arguments. Pretty much every constructor at this point needs to be explicit. All of these things come down to implicit conversions
我完全赞同C++不是一种强类型语言。而且为了让它变得更强类型，我们费了很大周折。我们编写强类型包装器。我们删除有问题的重载。我们编写以特定方式约束的模板。我们说，我的意思是，就像我们教单参数或可变参数构造函数，或者带默认参数的构造函数。基本上现在的每个构造函数都需要是显式的。所有这些都归结为隐式转换
that make the language less strongly typed. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 104 recorded on October 26, 2022. My name is Connor, and today I continue my conversation with Jason Turner. Speaking of conferences, we can switch to kind of episode two of this podcast, which is let us know what you've been up to for the last five months. How has it been? I mean, I'll link the final episode where you talk with Rob about sort of the reasons for ending CppCast. And I also saw that there was a, I think it was PVS Studio came out with a sort of interview style post. So it's a written form post if you want to go read that sort of dives into those details of, you know, why CppCast ended. So we don't need to necessarily go into detail. But if you want, feel free to mention why it ended, what it's been like for the last five months.
这使得该语言的强类型特性减弱。欢迎收听ADSP播客第104期，录制于2022年10月26日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我将继续与杰森·特纳（Jason Turner）对话。说到会议，我们可以转到这个播客的第二部分，也就是让我们了解一下你过去五个月都在忙些什么。感觉怎么样？我的意思是，我会附上最后一集的链接，在那集里你和罗布（Rob）谈论了结束CppCast的原因之类的事情。我还看到，我想是PVS Studio发布了一篇类似访谈风格的文章。所以如果你想去阅读，那是一篇文字形式的文章，里面深入探讨了那些细节，你知道的，为什么CppCast会结束。所以我们不一定需要深入探讨。但如果你愿意，可以随时提及它为什么结束，以及过去五个月感觉如何。
And then, you know, we mentioned that you sort of went to a couple of conferences. Yeah. Tell us what you've been up to, the talks you've been given, and we'll go from there. A couple of times Rob and I have chatted and we're after like a month or six weeks or so after we had ended CBP cast, we're like, wow, like my schedule feels just so incredibly different because there isn't the, you know, on Monday morning, make sure we have the show notes and the news items and the interview questions ready to go for the interview on Wednesday. Like we, like that was, uh, it was basically the only regular part of my schedule because I haven't been an employee in 13 years, I think of a corporation.
然后呢，我们提到你参加了几个会议。对，告诉我们你都在忙些什么，你做过哪些演讲，然后我们再接着聊。罗布和我聊过好几次，在我们结束CppCast大约一个月或六周后，我们感叹，哇，我的日程安排感觉太不可思议地不同了，因为没有了那种，你知道的，在周一早上，确保我们为周三的采访准备好节目大纲、新闻条目和采访问题的工作。就像我们，就像那是，基本上是我日程中唯一的固定部分，因为我想我已经有13年没在公司当过雇员了。
You're self-employed. I'm self-employed. I haven't had to directly answer to someone else about my schedule in a very long time, except for CVP cast. That was seven years of that. And that was my regular, like, we have to do these things several times a week kind of items on there. So it was kind of freeing in some ways to just be like, wow, my schedule feels different. I can, I don't know, it felt like I was just more available in some ways. One of the things that I really wanted to do was do more development on my second channel, which I've recently renamed. It was called the Retro Programmer. I renamed it to the Fill in the Blank Programmer because I just kind of wanted a space where I could
你是自雇的。我是自雇的。除了CppCast之外，我已经很久不需要就我的日程安排直接向其他人交代了。那是整整七年的时间。那是我的常规工作，就是那种我们一周必须做好几次的事情。所以在某种程度上，感觉挺自由的，只想感叹，哇，我的日程安排感觉不一样了。我能，我不知道，在某种程度上感觉自己更有空了。我真正想做的事情之一，就是在我的第二个频道上做更多的开发，我最近给它改了名。它以前叫“复古程序员”（The Retro Programmer）。我把它改名为“某某程序员”（The Fill in the Blank Programmer），因为我只是想要一个空间，在那里我可以
talk about anything programming related and not have to deal with like the YouTubers that are like, I don't like this content because it's not C++, you know? But to be fair, the name of the channel is C++ Weekly. So, right. So my plan was to do a new episode on that channel every other week. And I did like six weeks of that. But, you know, without the name forcing you to keep going, C++ Weekly, like that forces me to release an episode every week so um that was kind of hard i still have plans lots of plans for the other channel but i haven't spent as much time as i expected to but then i had two different contracts with one of my clients that i was trying to wrap up. So in between the other things, let's see, flew to
谈论任何与编程相关的话题，而不必应付那些说“我不喜欢这个内容，因为它不是C++”的油管博主，你知道吗？不过平心而论，这个频道的名称就叫C++周刊（C++ Weekly）。没错。所以我的计划是每隔一周在该频道发布一期新节目。我那样坚持了大约六周。但是，你知道的，没有了那个强迫你继续下去的名字——C++周刊，那个名字强迫我每周发布一期节目——所以，嗯，那确实挺难的。我仍然有计划，为另一个频道制定了许多计划，但我花在上面的时间没有预期的那么多。不过后来我有一个客户的两份不同合同需要我收尾。所以在处理其他事情的间隙，让我想想，我飞去了
England to speak at C++ on C in June, right? That was June, right? No, that's July. I think it was either late June or early July because that was, no, it must have been July because it was the week before, I think, CPP North. And CPP North was- It was two weeks before CPP North because Cause I did the week. Yeah. It was to the 28th through the 30th of June. Oh no, that's 2023. Nevermind. He already put up information for next week or for next year. Oh yeah. That's an irritating thing about some conferences is like tracking the dates and the talks by year. Uh, cause the main link always goes to whatever the most recent conferences is and uh some conferences are
英格兰，6月在C++ on Sea上发表演讲，对吧？那是6月，对吧？不对，那是7月。我想要么是6月下旬，要么是7月上旬，因为那是，不对，一定是7月，因为那是，我想是在CPP North的前一周。而CPP North是——那是CPP North的两周前，因为我做了一周。对。那是6月28日到30日。哦不对，那是2023年。算了。他已经把下周或明年的信息放上去了。哦对。有些会议令人恼火的一点是，需要按年份追踪日期和演讲。因为主链接总是指向最近的那次会议，而且有些会议
great about you can find a thing and click on a year i could just look at my own personal calendar that's beside the point i went and i did a workshop there and spoke um did the closing keynote at c++ on c and then drove from there to the to the Netherlands to do like my first on-site training in, uh, well, it had been seven months since I had done my last like training event. So I did, no, four months. Sorry. So I did that and then flew from the Netherlands to Toronto to go to C++ North and then flew home. So that was a three-week trip, which, like we were talking, 2019 was crazy. 2019, that would have been like, whatever, that's just January. 2022, you're like, oh my goodness, am I going to survive this?
很好，你可以找到内容并点击年份，我本可以直接查看我自己的个人日程表，但这题外话了。我去了并在那里做了一个讲习班，发表了演讲，——在C++ on Sea上发表了闭幕主题演讲，然后从那里开车前往荷兰，进行我的第一次现场培训，呃，好吧，距离我上一次进行类似的培训活动已经过去七个月了。所以我做了，不对，四个月。抱歉。所以我完成了那个，然后从荷兰飞往多伦多参加CPP North，接着飞回家。所以那是一次为期三周的旅行，就像我们之前讨论的，2019年太疯狂了。2019年，那感觉就像，管他呢，那只是1月。2022年，你会觉得，哦天哪，我能熬过去吗？
Yeah. Yeah. And we have to say, I have to say thank you, because you ended up giving two talks at CPP North. I did. You initially submitted and got accepted the power of Compile Time Resources, I believe. And then we ended up having a couple different speakers
对。对。我们必须说，我必须表达感谢，因为你最终在CPP North上做了两场演讲。我确实做了。我记得你最初提交并通过审核的是《编译期资源的威力》（The Power of Compile Time Resources）。然后我们最终有几个不同的演讲者
that didn't end up making it. You know, one of them, the airline was on strike. Oh, right. Like the days leading up to it. And anyways. Oh, goodness, right. That was Scandinavian era, right? Yeah. A couple of different reasons. We weren't able to have a couple of speakers. And so you
没能成行。你知道，其中一个人的航空公司在罢工。哦，对。就在临近的那几天。总之。哦，天哪，对。那是斯堪的纳维亚航空，对吧？对。由于几个不同的原因。我们没能请到几位演讲者。所以你
stepped up and gave a second talk, which was the best parts of C++, which is one of my favorite talks that you've given. You've given it at a previous conference before. And I love that talk because there's so many talks in C++ that focus on the warts of the language. Like I think even yourself, you've given talks about like why initializer list is broken. And, you know, so there's a ton of talks out there that focus on UB and crazy things and shooting yourself in the foot. And it's sort of, you know, goes hand in hand with C++. There are much fewer talks, at least from my, what I've observed of like, why this language is a great language and focusing on all the things that like as C++ professionals, we know everything bad about the language and it's very easy to,
挺身而出，做了第二场演讲，即《C++最好的一面》（The Best Parts of C++），这是你做过的我最喜欢的演讲之一。你之前在别的会议上讲过。我喜欢这个演讲，是因为C++中有很多演讲都专注于这门语言的缺点。比如我想甚至你自己也做过诸如“为什么初始化列表是坏的”之类的演讲。所以有很多演讲都专注于未定义行为（UB）和疯狂的事情，以及如何搬起石头砸自己的脚。这可以说，你知道的，与C++如影随形。而专注于这门语言为什么是一门伟大的语言、并关注作为C++专业人士我们了解这门语言的所有缺点却依然热爱它的各方面——这样的演讲要少得多，至少从我的观察来看是这样的。
you know, it's, I feel like it's almost that conferences. It's like the thing, it's like, oh, so what are we complaining about in this group of people? It's never, hey, let's talk about, you know, the ability to do generic programming in C++ and++ and the power that we have with insert this or insert that. And your talk sort of goes through, I can't remember if it's 15 things or 25 things, but it's all these, you know, a list of things. And you spend a few minutes on each one talking about like why this is great and why you should be excited about this in C++. So it's a very like positive oriented talk. And I remember watching it, one, feeling like this is refreshing to hear someone like talking about why they really like the language. But two, I was like, just found myself nodding the whole time. Every once in a while, you'd get to something like as simple as, you
你知道，我感觉在会议上几乎成了惯例，就像是，哦，我们这群人今天在抱怨什么呢？从来都不是，嘿，让我们来谈谈，你知道的，在C++中进行泛型编程的能力，以及我们通过插入这个或插入那个所拥有的强大功能。而你的演讲大致梳理了，我不记得是15件事还是25件事，但全是这些，你知道的，一系列的事情。你在每一项上花了几分钟时间，谈论为什么这很棒，以及为什么你该为C++的这一点感到兴奋。所以这是一个非常具有积极导向的演讲。我记得观看时，一方面觉得听到有人谈论他们为什么真的很喜欢这门语言，感觉令人耳目一新；另一方面，我发现自己一直在点头。每隔一段时间，你会讲到一些非常简单的事情，比如，你知道的，
know, the auto keyword for type inference. And it's like, well, that is actually like, it's amazing when you compare it to what you had to do back in like pre C++11, where you had to spell out all the namespaces and the iterator types. It's like, we take it for granted now as, you know, quote unquote, dealing in modern versions of the language, but like compared to what you had to use to write, it's amazing. And even like comparing the type inference in C++ compared to Rust, like a lot of times you have to spell things out in Rust and you forget that like, oh yeah, I can just deduce the type of this function returns because C++ is great at that stuff.
用于类型推导的auto关键字。这就好比，当你把它与C++11之前你必须写出所有命名空间和迭代器类型的时候进行对比，你会发现这其实太了不起了。我们现在认为这是理所当然的，作为，你知道的，所谓处理现代版本的语言的人，但与你以前必须编写的代码相比，这太棒了。甚至将C++中的类型推导与Rust进行比较，在Rust中很多时候你必须把东西完整拼写出来，而你却忘了，哦，对了，我可以推导这个函数返回的类型，因为C++在这方面非常出色。
And we take it for granted. And anyways, enough about how amazing that talk is. You can say more about the two talks you gave at CPP North. And then I just watched the one at C++ on C, which is making C++ fun, safe, and accessible. I think if I got the title right. That sounds right, yeah. So how did those all go?
而我们把这视为理所当然。不管怎样，对那场演讲有多精彩就说到这吧。你可以多谈谈你在CPP North上做的两场演讲。然后我刚刚看了你在C++ on Sea上的那场，也就是《让C++变得有趣、安全且易用》（Making C++ Fun, Safe, and Accessible）。我想我如果没记错标题的话。听起来对，是的。那么这些进展如何？
Well, okay. So I kind of want to rewind just a tad because that talk you said was your favorite came from that 2019 year when I was doing all the travel. And I had kind of set a public goal. I think I tweeted it even of being like more positive about the language and not just focusing on the words because it's too easy and too fun to do that. Basically, dunking is it's the best it's why twitter twitter you know insert posting is a thing for a reason and then i got invited to a keynote at um core c++ it's the first year in israel and uh in tel aviv and i thought
好吧，好的。所以我想稍微倒带一点，因为你说是你最喜欢的那场演讲，来自于2019年我到处旅行的那一年。我当时设定了一个公开的目标，我想我甚至发推特说过，就是对这门语言更加积极一点，不仅盯着缺点不放，因为这样做太容易也太好玩了。基本上，贬低它——这是最好的，这就是为什么推特，你知道的，发帖成为一种现象是有原因的。然后我被邀请在Core C++上做一个主题演讲，那是第一年在以色列特拉维夫举行，我想
well you know what like i I have strong opinions about what a keynote should be and I think keynotes should in general be um a positive experience about the language right like if the keynote speaker that you invited to the conference spends you know 30 minutes of their 90 minutes dunking on the language, I feel like it might not have been the best choice for a keynote. C++ keynote, why you should use Rust. You know, so I thought, well, I really have to like come up with something that's like really good and positive and focuses on the good things of the language.
好吧，你知道吗——我对主题演讲应该是什么样有强烈的看法，我认为主题演讲总体上应该是一个关于这门语言的积极体验，对吧？如果你邀请到会议上的主题演讲者在他们的90分钟里花了30分钟来贬低这门语言，我觉得这可能不是主题演讲的最佳选择。C++主题演讲：为什么你应该使用Rust。你知道的，所以我心想，好吧，我真的必须想出一些非常棒、非常积极、并且专注于这门语言好的一面的东西。
So that talk is specifically organized to be an evolution of the language. It kind of takes you from how ugly things were in C++98, from those of us who started with C++ then, to how clean and simple things can be with a few auto keywords arranged for loop and a concept or two thrown in or something like that. Right. Uh, and it's funny cause I still like, man, I get these people push back still sometimes on YouTube and on Twitter, they're like, auto is a dumpster fire. It doesn't actually help with anything. It just makes your code harder to read and whatever and and and and i'll come back and i'll say really like really you would rather type std colon colon vector std
所以那场演讲是专门为了展现这门语言的演进而组织的。它带你从C++98中事物是多么丑陋——对于我们这些当时从C++开始的人来说——一直走到使用几个auto关键字、一个范围for循环以及加入一两个概念或类似东西的代码是多么干净和简单。对。而且很有意思，因为我仍然，天哪，我在YouTube和推特上仍然有时会遭到这些人的反弹，他们会说，auto就是一个垃圾场。它实际上对任何事情都没有帮助。它只会让你的代码更难读，无论如何、无论如何、无论如何……然后我会反驳说，真的吗？真的吗？你宁愿输入std::vector这样的东西吗？——这真的是你宁愿输入的吗？而人们反弹说：是的，因为那样我知道我的程序在做什么。然后我，嗯，呃。不。不。不，我经历过。我曾经那样做好长时间。不，这个绝对更好。
colon colon string colon colon const underscore iterator like that's really what you want to type instead and people push back with like yes because then I know what my program is doing. And I, hmm, eh. No. No. No, I've been there. I did that for a long time. No, this is definitely better.
对。我100%属于“几乎总是auto”阵营。别误会我。我喜欢来来回回的玩笑话。你知道的，我看过有人做演讲提倡这个，然后结束时的问答环节就是人们走上前来问：这种情况怎么办？那个情况怎么办？是的，这就是编程。很多时候这取决于具体情况。但就你刚刚解释的观点而言，我不知道你怎么能反其道而行之，去争辩说——
Yeah. I am 100% in the almost always auto camp. And don't get me wrong. I love the banter back and forth. You know, I've seen people give talks where they abrogate for this, and then the Q&A at the end is just people coming up. What about this case? And what about, yes, that is programming. It depends a lot of the times. But for what you just explained, I don't know how you can argue in the opposite direction that like-
哦，人们会这么做。很多时候，甚至当你使用auto时，通过查看等号右侧的内容，你也可以在很大程度上获得很好的感觉，甚至确切地知道你正在获取的东西的类型是什么。真有趣，你遇到了这种反弹，但你知道的，这就是YouTube、推特和红迪网（Reddit）留给你的东西，你知道为什么不把它们一网打尽呢？当我在进行培训且auto成为话题时，我通常提出的论点是：你在乎这个东西的类型是什么吗？你真的在乎vector.size的类型是什么吗？99%的情况下，答案是：不，我知道它是一个整型。我不在乎具体类型是什么。如果你真的想要，
Oh, people do. You can a lot of the times, even when you're using auto, by looking to what's at the right of the equal sign, you can a lot of the like get a great sense or even know exactly what the type of the thing is that you're getting interesting that you get that pushback but i you know that's that's youtube and twitter for you and reddit you know why not while we're throwing them all under the bus and when i'm doing like training and auto comes up the argument i generally make is, do you care what the type of this thing is? Do you really care what the type of vector dot size is? And 99% of the time, the answer is no, I know it's an integral thing. I don't care what the type is. And if you really want to,
你知道的，用std::integral或类似的约束它。对。反正我不在福。所以，我试着指出，选择不在乎具体类型是什么，要好于不小心引发隐式转换，把它变成你以为它应该是的那个类型。对。我知道我在C++开发的头一份工作里就引发过至少一个Bug，当时我没有使用auto，我用的是short或者int32_t什么的，而它返回的是long long或者别的什么。我们有一些规则，就是说，你知道的，我们不应该使用auto，但因为那是一个数值保险计算器，我们关闭了——这会刺痛你的心，因为我知道你对此的看法。
you know, constrain it with stood integral, or whatever. Right. Like I don't care. And, and so I try to point out that I think choosing to not care what the exact type is, is better than accidentally invoking an implicit conversion to the type that you thought that it should be. Yeah. There's been, I know at least one bug that I caused in my first job as a C++ dev where I was using not auto, I was using short or something or, you know, in 32T and it was returning a long, long or something. And we had some rule that like, you know, we're not supposed to use auto, but because it was a numeric insurance calculator, we had turned off and this is going to hurt your soul. Cause I know your views on this.
我们关闭了诸如-Wall和-Wno-conversion之类的警告。这最终导致了一个由客户报告的Bug，因为那个long long像是一个表ID，结果被截断了。因此导致了程序崩溃。我最后做了一个内部演讲，或者说闪电演讲。其实没那么长，基本上就是说：如果我们使用auto，这个Bug本可以避免，因为我就不必去关心这个表ID的类型是什么。或者如果你开启了-Wconversion，也可以通过这种方式抓出来。我的意思是，看到所有被关闭的警告，会让你心碎的。而且，呃，我的意思是，我觉得我们到处都有从浮点到double的显式或隐式转换——到处都是，还有到bool的转换。是的，确实如此。我赞同你说的，遵循入门项目的做法，默认开启所有警告。然后，你就不用在以后担心这些事情了。但话又说回来，我的论点是：使用auto。然后我们就能避免那个Bug了。所以你是在暗指我最近一直在狂热反对隐式转换这件事？
We had turned off like the W all and W no conversion. And this ended up in like a bug that got reported by a client because the long long was like a table ID and it got truncated. And so it ended up in a crash. And like I ended up giving an internal talk or like lightning talk. It wasn't that long, basically being like this bug would have been avoided if we had used auto, because I wouldn't have to care about what the, what the type of this, you know, table ID, you know, what's. Or if you could have turned on W conversion, it would have been caught that way too. I mean, it would, it would break your heart to see all the warnings that are turned off. And, and, um, I mean, I think we had explicit or implicit
我猜你在推特上看到了一些这方面的内容。我在推特上看到了一些，但我想这浮现在脑海里，仅仅是因为我刚看完你在C++ on Sea上的演讲，你在其中提到了这一点。还有你最近的C++周刊视频也谈到了这一点，以及如果你只是打开了W杠或杠W，你知道的，插入所有这些东西，这些Bug是如何可以避免的。嗯，只有-Wconversion才是我目前正在狂热反对的。这就是我的意思，是的，我也希望有所有其他的警告。但这是我发现历史上最难说服人们去使用的警告。
conversions from like floating to double, like all over the place and conversions to bool. Yes, it was. I'm with you that follow the starter project, turn everything on by default. And then like, you just don't have to worry about that stuff down the road. But yeah, my argument was like, use auto. And then we would have, we would have avoided the bug. So you're alluding to the fact that I've been on a little bit of a rampage about conversion lately.
所以我的一位朋友从事与安全相关的工作，不是C++，但他有时会发给我一些东西，说：看看这段C++代码里的这个Bug。我看了看，通常能相对较快地把它指出来，因为我有C++经验。对他来说，这门语言比较陌生。但他就是把PlayStation的Bug发给我的人。我看了看，他说：是的，这个错误对我和不太明显。我看了看然后说：-Wconversion会立即捕捉到这个错误。于是我开始做更多的调查，
I'm assuming you've seen some of that on Twitter. I have seen some of it on Twitter, but I think it's top of mind just because I just finished watching the C++ on C talk where you bring it up. And then also your most recent C++ weekly video talked about it as well and how the bugs could have been avoided if you just turned on the W dash or dash W, you know, insert all the things. Well, just W conversion is the one that I'm only rampaging on at the moment. That's the one that I mean, like, yes, I want all the other ones too. But that's the one that I have found historically is the most difficult to convince people to use.
这我以前从未真正做过，但我开始像浏览cert数据库一样浏览，目前我已经在cert数据库、CVE数据库中至少识别出了10个相当重大的安全Bug，不好意思，CVE数据库——C++程序中的10个重大Bug，这些Bug如果加上-Wconversion就能被捕捉到。安全漏洞，哇——大事啊。对，C和C++代码，不全是C++代码——所以我过去两天一直在推特上谈论这个，就好像，“哦，还有谁想看另一个会被-Wconversion捕捉到的安全漏洞吗？”我仍然
So I did one of my friends does security related work, not C++, but he'll send me things sometimes where he says, look at this bug that was in the C++ code. And I look at it, and I can oftentimes spot it relatively quickly because I'm experienced with C++. For him, the language is less familiar. But he's the one who sent me the PlayStation bug. And I looked at it, and he's like, yeah, this, this error is less obvious to me. I look at it and I say W conversion would have caught that immediately. And so I start doing some more looking,
在推特上遇到有人反弹说：“哦，这太吵闹了。它其实抓不到什么有用的东西。”而我则说：“我刚刚向你展示的那个安全漏洞，它就能抓到。”我认为问题在于很多公司从一开始就没有默认开启这些东西。所以让他们事后尝试开启，会导致成千上万条警告。但这就好比，如果你在启动一个新项目，比如绿地项目，拥有静态分析器真是太棒了。我把它们视为编程拥抱。我从——你知道的，做了一点Rust编程中借用了这个词。它就像Rust编译器。这就像Rust与没有开启所有分析器和警告的C++之间的区别。它就像是：
which I've never really done before, but I start like browsing through the cert database and I've so far identified at least 10 fairly major security bugs that are in the cert database, CVEsves database excuse me cve database of um 10 major bugs and c++ programs that would have been caught with dash w conversion security flaws wow like big deals yeah c c and c++ code not all c++ code um so i've been i've been going at this on twitter for the last two days, just like, oh, does anyone else want to see another security flaw that would have been caught with WConversion? And I still
嘿，你在做这个。你不需要这样做。你想这样做吗？然后，它会给你提出你应该怎么做的建议。你会觉得：哇，那——谢谢你，这太好了。就像——谢谢你，这太好了，这就是警告的作用。把它调到失败级别，然后就会发现：哦，这行不通——而且我得承认，C++的警告没那么好——但对于许多最基本的警告，比如类型转换，它们准确地指出了问题所在，就像是：哦，你在这样做，你想这样做吗？然后就像是：呃，不，我不想这样做。非常感谢！这就好像有一个好朋友站在旁边，把胳膊搭在你的肩膀上说：嘿，老兄，你是故意这么做的吗？然后就像是：你说得对，我不是故意要这么做的。非常感谢！
have people pushing back on Twitter like, oh, it's just too noisy. It doesn't actually catch anything useful. And I'm like, that security bug right there that I just showed you would have caught. I think the problem is that a lot of companies don't have this stuff on default from the beginning. And so having them try and turn it on after the fact leads to like thousands and thousands of things. But it's like, if you're starting a new project like Greenfield, it is so nice to have static analyzers. Like I consider them like programming hugs. Like, and I term that from like, you know, doing a little bit of rust programming. It's like the rust compiler. It's just like the difference between rust and like C plus plus without all the analyzers and warnings turned on. It's just like,
这并不是那种会碍手碍脚的东西。如果你从一开始就使用它，它就像是一个好朋友在你的肩膀上盯着。嗯，我也发现这重构了我的编程方式。所以我更不可能去编写那种从一开始就会触发这些警告的代码。对。对。确实如此。格式化也是同样的道理，很多时候你可以某种程度上预测什么时候某段代码在格式化时会表现得糟糕透顶。所以你会调整构建某些东西的方式，不是从语义上，而只是以某种方式。所以，我要问你一个问题。好的。Rust不允许隐式转换，对吧？
Hey, you're doing this. You don't need to do this. Do you want to do this? And then like, gives you a suggestion of what you should do. And you're like, wow, that's well, thank you for that. That's very nice. Uh, and it's like, that's well thank you for that that's very nice uh and it's like that's what warnings are it's like turn them to fail and it's like oh this didn't work like and i will give you this the c plus plus's warnings aren't as good um but for a lot of the bread and butter ones like conversions they point exactly at what the problem is and it's just like oh you're doing do you want to do this and it's like uh yeah i don't want to well thank you very much it's just like having a nice friend there that like puts their arm around your shoulder and says hey buddy uh did you mean to do this and it's like you're right i didn't want to, well, thank you very much. It's just like having a nice friend there that like puts their arm around your shoulder and says, hey buddy, did you mean to do this?
对。C++中有没有什么隐式转换是你希望Rust其实也拥有的？我不这么认为。C++中有一些部分，在学习并在编程竞赛中使用过它们之后，它们是一些捷径，如果你知道自己在做什么，它们真的很棒。比如在哈希映射上，比如unordered_map或map，它会自动插入或使用默认值之类的。而在Python等其他语言中，你不能对字典这样做。你必须使用一个名为defaultdict的专用集合。那是一个很好的小技巧，当我试图为竞赛快速编写某些东西时，我喜欢有这个功能。而且我喜欢我可以在while循环中将一个整型用作布尔值，而不必写诸如“不等于零”之类的内容来具现化那个布尔值。
And it's like, you're right. I didn't mean to do that. Thank you very much. And it's not something that gets in the way. It's something that if you use it from the beginning, it's just like having a nice friend staring over your shoulder. Well, and I also find it kind of reprograms how I program. So I'm less likely to write code that would ever invoke those warnings in the first place. Yeah. Yeah. That's, it's true. That's the same way with formatting is a lot of the times you can sort of predict when something is going to get, is going to do terribly in formatting. So you'll adjust the way that you're structuring something, not semantically, but just sort of anyway. So, so I'm going to ask you a question though though. Okay. Rust doesn't allow implicit conversions, right?
所以像这样的类型检查，诸如此类。我喜欢为了——你知道的，为了黑客编程和快速推进而使用它们。但如果我在编写生产代码，我不认为隐式转换是我会从C++中怀念的——Rust中确实有一些缺失的东西，但隐式转换不是其中之一。为什么你会——有什么转换是你怀念的吗？或者我知道你做过一点编程，因为我看过你过去和你的表弟一起做的直播。对，不，我只是玩过Rust，但既然我现在正在进行关于隐式转换的这番狂热抱怨，我越来越
Correct. Are there any implicit conversions from C++ that you wish Rust actually did? I don't think so. There are parts of C++ that having learned it and used it in coding competitions that are shortcuts that are like, if you know what you're doing, are really nice. equal on a hash map, like an unordered map or map, it'll automatically insert or use the default value or something. Whereas like in other languages like Python, you can't do that with the dictionary. You have to use a specialized collection called the default dictionary. That is a nice hack that like when I'm trying to write something really quickly for a competition, I like that that's there. And I like that I can use an integer as a Boolean value in a while loop and not have to do like a not equal to zero to materialize that Boolean.
确信：如果我们有一个禁用隐式转换的编译器标志，C++中至少50%的尖锐边缘将不复存在。有趣。这基于什么？——这只是思考我自己的培训材料得出的结论。我想：哇，如果我们没有隐式转换，这一节就无关紧要了，那一节就无关紧要了，这一节也无关紧要了。是的。我的意思是，我知道在我工作过的多家公司中我见过的一整类Bug，它们是多种因素结合在一起的，但比如你有参数——我见过这样的Bug：你有一长串参数，其中一些是指针，一些是布尔值，然后他们把顺序搞混了，其中一个就会发生隐式转换。而且
So like it type checks, things like that. I like for like, you know, being doing hacking and going really quickly. But like if I'm writing production code, I don't think implicit conversions are something that there are things that are not in Rust that I miss, but from C++. But yeah, implicit conversions is not one of them. Why do you, are there conversions that you miss? Or I know you've done a little bit of programming because I've seen the live stream that you did with your cousin back in the day. Yeah, no, I've only toyed with Rust, but since I'm on this rant about implicit conversions right now, I'm becoming increasingly
我也见过这样的情况：你有一长串参数和一些默认参数，然后其中一个会隐式转换。我还见过：你有一长串参数和一些默认参数，然后你忘了那里有默认值。总之——而且其中一部分只是：不要把三个布尔值紧挨着指针或其他东西放。问题在于阅读代码时，你根本不知道true、false、true、true意味着什么。但如果真的不允许隐式转换，我想所有这些Bug都会消失。如果我们没有隐式转换，我们甚至都不必教什么是对象切割。
convinced that I'm going to go with at least 50% of the sharp edges in C++ would no longer exist if we had a compiler flag to disable implicit conversions. Interesting. That's based on what, like just thinking through my own training material. And I'm like, wow, if we didn't have implicit conversions, this section wouldn't matter. This section wouldn't matter. This section wouldn't matter. Yeah. I mean, I know a whole category of bugs that I've seen in multiple companies that I've worked at where it's a combination of things, but like you have arguments, you know, I've seen both the bug where you have a long list of arguments, some of which are pointers and some of which are booleans, and then they mix up the order and then one will implicitly convert. And
是的。我总体上更喜欢静态类型和强类型。而隐式转换打破了强类型。是的。我正想说C++不是一种强类型语言，正是因为它把隐式转换内建到了语言中。是的，这是一个极好的——不一定是题外话，但——所以，正是因为它把隐式转换内建到了语言中。动态类型、强/弱类型，我当时在想：究竟什么是强类型？因为静态与动态是按定义划分的，但强与弱似乎只是一种观点。彼得（Peter）当时在争论，我记得我曾问过——如果你回看那场演讲，
I've also seen where you have a long list of parameters and some default arguments, and then one will implicitly convert. And I've also seen where you have a long list of parameters and some default arguments, and then you forget like that there's defaults there. And anyways, and like some of that is just like, don't put three Booleans in a row next to pointers or whatever. It's just that reading the code, you have no idea what true, false, true, true means. But yeah, if implicit conversions weren't allowed, that would like, I think all of those bugs would disappear. We wouldn't have to teach what object slicing is if we didn't have implicit conversions.
我可以把它放到链接里——我记得我当时问过：你怎么能说C++是强类型的？它把一切都隐式转换了。与Haskell、Java相比，它是一门较弱的语言。你怎么能称它为强类型？然后每个人，房间里的每个人，或者至少大多数回答问题的人，彼得说：它是强类型的，如果你想让它是强类型的话——你可以把你的编程代码设计成强类型的。但我当时想：好吧，如果你在定义自定义类型等等。但是，这就像是你可以选择编写一个强类型程序，但该语言默认并不是强类型的。而且，可能会有一些人在听这个时，会在推特上回复说：不，C++
Yeah. I prefer static typing in general and strong typing. And implicit conversions break strong typing. Yeah. I was going to say C++ is not a strongly typed language, specifically because it has implicit conversions baked into the language. Yeah, this is a great, well, not necessarily tangent, but like, so, specifically because it has implicit conversions baked into the language. dynamic typing strong weak and i was trying to figure out like what what is strongly typed because like static versus dynamic is like it's by definition but like strong versus weak just seems to be an opinion and peter was arguing and i remember asking if you go back and watch the talk
是强类型的。但如果在语言排名中，它落后了，我认为它落后于Python，可能Python比C++更强类型，但关于“是什么让一门语言变强”的争论也是如此。你问不同的程序员、软件工程师或编程语言研究人员，他们会给出不同的答案。有些人认为隐式转换与一个类型是否是强类型没有任何关系。我大概有点好奇那个论点是什么。我完全赞同C++不是一种强类型语言。而且为了让它变得更强类型，我们费了很大周折。
i can throw it in the links i remember asking like how can you say like c++ is strong like it implicitly converts everything like compared to haskell compared to java it's a weaker language like how can you call it strong and then everybody everybody in the room, or at least most of the people that were answering and Peter said, like, it's strong, if you want it to be strong, like you can design your programming code to be strong. But I was like, okay, so if you're defining custom types, etc. But like, but that's like, so you can opt in and write a strong program, but like the language by default is not strong. And like, there are some people that are probably listening to this, but that'll respond on Twitter being like, no, C++
我们编写强类型包装器。我们删除有问题的重载。我们编写以特定方式约束的模板。我们教单参数或可变参数构造函数，或者带默认参数的构造函数。基本上现在的每个构造函数都需要是显式的。我们认为任何转换运算符都需要是显式的。然后我们看到这些人发推特说C++是一个垃圾场，因为你可以做一些诸如将int传递给string的构造函数之类的事情，而你基本上根本不知道它会做什么。所有这些都归结为隐式转换，这使得该
is strong. But like, on a ranking of languages, like it falls, I think it falls below like Python, I think Python is more strongly typed than C++ is potentially, but also like the argument of what makes a strong language. It's like you ask a different programmer or software engineer or PL person, and they'll give you a different answer. Some people don't think that implicit conversions has anything to do with whether a type is strongly typed or not. I guess I'm moderately curious what that argument is. I'm fully in the camp of C++ is not a strongly typed language. And we jump through a lot of hoops to try to make it more strongly typed.
语言的强类型特性减弱。如果理论上我可以传递一个int，或者一个布尔值——好吧，你可以传递一个布尔值，对吧？你可以把布尔值传给一个期望得到string的函数，因为它会隐式地为标准string构造函数找到const char*重载。而这并不是你想要它做的事。对吧？所以我不认为它是强类型的。你在这里听到了第一手消息。杰森不这么认为。我不这么认为。网上有大量的演讲。我会试着找几个。我会找到彼得的那场。是的，我不知道是不是C++开发者就是不愿意承认其他语言在这方面更好。而且，你可以得到很多东西。我最近发现的一个我在编程中最喜欢的东西是：Haskell有一个基于它们称之为类型签名的函数搜索引擎，但在C++或C中，它只是一个函数签名。所以你可以，
We write strongly typed wrappers. We delete problematic overloads. We write templates that are constrained in specific ways. We teach single parameter or variadic constructors or constructors with default arguments. Pretty much every constructor at this point needs to be explicit. Any conversion operator, we argue, needs to be explicit. And then we see these people tweeting about how C++ is a dumpster fire because you can do something like pass an int to the constructor for a string and you have no idea what it's going to do, basically. All of these things come down to implicit conversions that make the
你知道的，如果你想找到所有接受一个vector并返回一个vector的函数，你可以在Haskell中做到这一点，因为它拥有令人惊叹的类型推导引擎，而且它是如此的强类型。Rust也有某种程度的——它没有那么惊人，因为Rust中有各种各样不同的类型，但它有一个叫做rugh(注：此处指Rust的类似工具)的东西，我猜这是对hugel的恶搞，而hugel是对Haskell Google的恶搞。有人回应说：Go算什么？如果Go有一个，他们打算叫它什么？因为这个名字已经被占用了。
language less strongly typed. If I can pass an int theoretically, or a Boolean, well, you can pass a Boolean, right? You can pass a Boolean to a function expecting a string because it's going to implicitly find the const character pointer overload for standard string constructor. And that's not what you wanted it to do. Right? So I don't think it's strongly typed. You heard it here first. Jason doesn't think so. I don't think so. And there's a ton of talks online. I'll try and find a few of them. I'll find the Peter one. Yeah, I'm not sure if it's C++ devs that they just don't like to admit that other languages are better when it comes to this. And like, you can get so much stuff. I just recently discovered one of my
但你知道的，C++，我认为由于隐式转换的存在，真的永远不可能拥有这样的东西。你可以拥有一个非常简陋的版本，但它实际上无法捕获所有可能奏效的不同东西。好吧，你可以得到，是的——我的意思是，有些工具相当接近——我想如果在CLion中，如果你输入像函数名加左括号，它会以统一调用语法（UFCS）的方式向你展示：要么是你正在输入的下一个类型的所有可能成员函数，要么是所有可以将该类型作为函数参数的东西。所以它非常接近，但没有——没有达到那种程度。我听说过，我看到了JetBrains发布的关于那个CLion功能的推特，我想我转发了
favorite things in programming is Haskell has a function search engine based on, they call it type signature, but in C++ or C, it's just a function signature. And so you can, you know, if you want to find all the functions that take a vector and return a vector, you can do that in haskell because it's such a it's got an amazing type inference engine and it's so strongly typed and rust has a sort of it's not as amazing because of all the different you know types that you can have in rust but it has something called rugel which is uh i guess a play on hugel which is a play on, you know, Haskell Google. Someone, someone responded, what is Go? If Go has one, what are they going to call it? Because it's already taken.
类似这样的内容：如果这是真的——那太了不起了，因为这正是你想要UFCS或面向对象这种范式的原因之一，你可以拥有这种点补全，你知道的，你在一个对象上打一个点，然后它就可以轻松建议所有可以随之而来的东西。如果没有这个，如果你只是调用自由函数，那就难得多。但据我所听说的，CLion做得相当不错。它确实有效，是的。虽然有时它让我感到困惑，因为我在想：我不是在找自由函数。我在找成员函数。而它们却说：哦，对了，这样做是为了帮倒忙。好吧，这真是太棒了。瞧瞧这个。为JetBrains免费赞助。我们有这个节目的赞助商吗？不，不，不。我们收到了很多公司的联系，
But like, you know, C++, I don't think could really ever have something like that because of the implicit conversions. Like you could have a very poor form of it, but like, it's not actually going to capture what all the different, you know, things that could possibly work. Well, you can get, yeah, I i mean some tools get pretty close-ish like i think in sea lion if you type like function name open paren it will show you like in a uniform call syntax way both all of the things that could be member functions on the next type that you're typing in or all the things that could take that type as a function parameter so it gets pretty close but not no not to that extent i've heard that i saw the tweet that jet brains did about the that c-line feature and i think i retweeted
但这是其中一件事，除非有某种巨大的、能改变人生的巨额资金。我不认为我喜欢拥有不间断的赞助商和快速的片尾。尽管有些人抱怨，他们说：我们不知道那一集要结束了。你本可以给我们提前30秒打个招呼的。因为很多时候我只是生硬地切断。然后说：感谢收听，再见。请关注下周的下一集。对。现在就订阅。好吧。不过我们刚才在聊天。我们扯开了好几次话题。我们当时在谈论C++ on Sea / CPP North
instead of like if this is true like that's that's amazing because that's kind of one of the arguments for why you want like a ufcs um uh sort of paradigm or like you know object oriented where you can have this sort of dot completion you know you go dot on an object and then it can easily suggest you everything that can come and without that if you're just calling free functions it's a lot harder but supposedly i've heard c line has pretty good it does work yeah although sometimes it confuses me because I'm like, I wasn't looking for a free function. I was looking for a member. And they're like, oh, right.
以及在那里发生的演讲。哦，对，过去五个月。是的。所以，C++ on Sea进展如何？讲习班进展如何？你的演讲怎么样？我的讲习班只有一个付费学生。其余的全是志愿者。
It's doing this to be helpful. Okay. That is pretty awesome. Look at that. Free sponsorship for JetBrains. Do we have a sponsor for this show? No, no, no. We've been reached out by a bunch of companies.
哦，哇。然后我原本应该在CPPCon上办的讲习班被取消了，因为报名人数不够。对于会议的现场讲习班来说，今年是个糟糕的年份。这就是我所观察到的。但我不知道它们在CPP North上进展如何，因为我没有在那里办讲习班。如果我没记错的话——我可能会记错——但我认为平均水平远低于我们的预期。但我认为每个班里至少有4到7个人。而且我知道其中一个班最初好像有6个人左右。
But it's one of the things that until there there's some huge monetary like life changing amount of money. I don't think I like having the uninterrupted sponsors and quick outro. Although some people complain, they're like, we didn't know that episode was going to end. You could have given us like a 30 second heads up because a lot of the times I just like hard cut. And it says thanks for listening. Bye. Wait for next week for the next episode. Yeah. Subscribe now. All right. We were talking though. We took a couple of tangents. We were talking about C++ on C slash CPP North
然后有两三个最终没能来，因为还是老原因——旅行问题。对。但我的意思是，看起来本来好像会类似于，你知道的，一两个学生，但我想每个班最终都有——至少我想大概是在4到7人的范围内。如果我离谱地猜错了，敬请期待未来的某一集，迈克·多姆（Mike Dom）私信我并说：“你怎么能猜得这么离谱？每个班有17个人呢。”是的。嗯，不过无论如何，听起来——是的，可能不像三年前那样了，当时在一个中等规模的会议上，你预计每个班有大约10到30名学生。
and the talks that happened there. Oh yes, the last five months. Yeah. So yeah, how did C++ on C go? How did the workshop go? How'd your talk go? I had one paid student in my workshop. The rest were volunteers.
以及在那里进行的演讲。哦，是的，过去五个月。是的。所以，C++ on C 进展如何？研讨会怎么样？你的演讲怎么样？我的研讨会只有一个付费学员，其余的都是志愿者。
Oh, wow. And then the workshop that I was supposed to give at CBPCon got canceled because there wasn't enough people signed up. This was a bad year for on-site workshops for conferences. That is what I observed. But I don't know how they went at C++ North because I didn't give one there. If I recall correctly, I'm going to get this wrong, but I think on average it was way lower than what we had hoped. But I think there was at least four to seven in each class. And I know one of them I think originally had six or something.
哦，哇。然后我本打算在 CppCon 上举办的研讨会被取消了，因为报名人数不够。对于会议的线下研讨会来说，今年是不太好的一年。这是我的观察。但我不知道它们在 C++ North 的情况如何，因为我在那里没有举办。如果我没记错的话，我可能会记错，但我认为平均人数远低于我们的预期。不过我想每个班至少有四到七个人。而且我知道其中一个班最初好像有六个人左右。
And then two or three didn't end up able to coming because once again, travel problems. Right. But I think, I mean, it looked like it was going to be similar to like, you know, one or two students, but I think each one ended up having, at least I want to say it was in like the four to seven range. If I'm drastically off, you know, look forward to a future episode where I will correct this after Mike Dom DMs me and he's like, how'd you get it so wrong? There was 17 in each class. Yeah. Well, but regardless, it sounds like, yeah, probably not like it was three years ago, where at a reasonably sized conference, you expected around 10 to 30 students in each class
然后有两三个人最后没能来，因为又是旅行问题。对的。但我觉得，嗯，看起来似乎和那种只有一两个学员的情况差不多，不过我想每个班最后都有，至少我想说是在四到七人的范围内。如果我错得离谱，你知道的，期待未来的某期节目，Mike Dom 给发私信说“你怎么能错得这么离谱？每个班有 17 个人呢”，然后我会再纠正。是的。无论如何，听起来，是的，可能不像三年前那样了，当时在规模适中的会议上，你期望每个班大约有 10 到 30 名学员
or something like that. Yeah. It was a lot smaller, I think. Yeah. But the conferences were all good. I had direct exposure to COVID at the speaker's dinner at C++ on C. And then I had direct exposure to COVID at the speakers dinner at C++ North. So I skipped the speakers dinner at CppCon because I decided I just didn't want to go down that road again. Did you manage to dodge COVID in both instances? Yeah, as far as I know. I mean, over the last, how long has it been since we did this thing? Two, almost three years, right? All of 2020, 2021, 2022, almost. I've had like, I don't know, two or three weeks in total that I felt like I feel kind of run down. I should take a relaxing day tomorrow. But as far as I know, I've never, I haven't even had a cold, like because of all the things, I guess. And I'm the kind of person who usually gets, like, a bad cold once a year.
诸如此类吧。是的。我觉得范围小了很多。不过会议都挺不错的。在C++ on C的演讲者晚宴上，我直接接触到了新冠。然后在C++ North的演讲者晚宴上，我又直接接触到了新冠。所以我跳过了CppCon的演讲者晚宴，因为我决定不想再经历一次了。你设法在两次事件中都躲过新冠了吗？是的，据我所知。我是说，在过去，我们做这件事有多久了？两年，快三年了，对吧？差不多经历了整个2020、2021、2022年。我大概，不知道，总共有一两周觉得身体有点吃不消。明天我得放松一天。但据我所知，我从来没有，我甚至没感冒过，我想大概是因为各种防护措施吧。而且我通常是那种每年都会得一次重感冒的人。
So, didn't have a cold. I've never tested positive for COVID. Between C++ on C and CPP North, I took a COVID test an average of, like, every other day just to see how I was doing. And they all came back negative. Well, that's what I know. That's, that's pretty lucky. I mean, I know that for most of the times, not the dinner, obviously when folks are eating, but it was a mass conference at C++ North. I'm, I'm not sure if C++ on C, but obviously that helps if you're, uh, if folks are masking, at least when you can, obviously, if you're putting a piece on C was not a mass conference, but the weather was good enough. And the way that venue is set up, we generally speaking had pretty good airflow through the conference.
所以，我没感冒过。我也从来没有测出新冠阳性。在C++ on C和CPP North之间，我平均大概每两天就做一次新冠测试，看看自己情况怎么样。结果全都是阴性。好吧，这就是我所知道的。这，这挺幸运的。我是说，我知道在大多数情况下，当然吃饭时除外，大家都在吃东西，但在C++ North这是一个大型会议。我，我不太确定C++ on C是不是，但很显然，如果大家，呃，如果大家戴着口罩，至少在可以的时候，当然，如果C++ on C不是一个大型会议，但天气足够好。而且那个场地的布局方式，总体来说我们在会议期间有相当不错的空气流通。
Right. But there was five or six people who tested positive after that one, like relatively low numbers still. And generally, I think C++ North, I don't know the total numbers, there was one or two people that tested positive. They were at my table at the speaker's dinner. Oh, were they? Yes. Because I got an email saying, just so you know, two people at your table at the speaker's dinner tested positive. Yeah, that's always concerning. I can't remember if they might have been. I mean mean i'm sure i had close exposure as well i got a email um but yeah luckily i mean at the time i think i was triple vaccinated and had already had it in i think it was earlier this year i went skiing and ended up
对的。但在那之后有五六个人测试呈阳性，这数字相对来说还是挺低的。总的来说，我觉得C++ North，我不知道具体数字，有一两个人测试呈阳性。他们就坐在我演讲者晚宴的桌子旁。哦，是吗？是的。因为我收到了一封邮件说，提醒你一下，你演讲者晚宴桌上的两个人检测呈阳性。是的，那总是挺让人担心的。我不记得他们是不是。我是说，我确信我也有过密切接触，我收到了一封邮件，嗯，但是是的，幸运的是，当时我想我打了三针疫苗，而且之前已经得过了，我想是今年早些时候我去滑雪，最后
getting it uh and it was pretty bad actually because i had missed my third vaccine i think it was my third vaccine i was registered to get on a monday and then the ski trip was a friday to saturday and then there was a snowstorm on the monday and my uh appointment got canceled and i tried to rebook and then they rebooked it for like the friday that i was leaving and so i didn't end up getting it caught covid and then basically was like dying for four days but uh and then i ended up getting like the booster the third vaccine like a week after that which two days after i got that they then said oh if you just recovered from covid wait like eight weeks right because you don't really need it so then there was like a period where i was like ultra ultra like safe from it because I had both a booster vax and had just recovered from it.
得了这病，嗯，其实挺严重的，因为我错过了第三针疫苗，我想那是我的第三针疫苗，我原本预约在周一去打，然后滑雪之旅是周五到周六，接着周一有一场暴风雪，我的预约被取消了，我试图重新预约，他们把预约改到了我要离开的那个周五，所以我最后没打成，结果感染了新冠，然后基本上快死去了四天，但是，后来差不多一周后我还是去打了加强针，也就是第三针，而在我打完两天后，他们就说，哦，如果你刚从新冠中康复，等大约八周吧，对吧，因为你其实不需要。所以当时有一段时间我对它可以说是超级超级安全，因为我既打了加强针又刚刚从新冠中康复。
But anyways, good to know that you dodged. I dodged it all. And I'm planning to get my bivalent or whatever fourth shot booster before I make my next round of travel. Yeah, yeah. I think those became available recently in Canada as well. Yeah, I should get that whenever we have still like two or three max mass vaccination sites set up and i thought that our state had like shut them down i guess they had shut down not the vaccination sites but they had shut down the mass testing
不管怎样，很高兴知道你躲过了。我全都躲过了。我打算在进行下一轮旅行之前去打二价疫苗或第四针加强针之类的。对，对。我想这些最近在加拿大也上市了。对，只要我们还有两三个大型疫苗接种点设置好，我就应该去打。我以为我们州已经关闭了它们，我想他们关闭的不是疫苗接种点，而是关闭了大型检测
centers is what they had done here yeah and so i'm like well i don't know how hard is it to get an appointment or whatever so i go and look and it's like which vaccine would you like and full drop down box like oh i think i'll take the bivalent from pfizer and they're like okay go to this location and see if there's any bookings available and i look and there's four spots available every single hour of every single day so how times have changed. I'm not sure if that was the case in the States, but in Canada, I mean, trying to get a vaccine. I remember having like six browsers
中心，这里的情况就是这样。所以我当时想，好吧，我不知道预约有多难或者别的什么，于是我去查看，上面写着你想接种哪种疫苗，下面是一个完整的下拉菜单，哦，我觉得我选辉瑞的二价疫苗吧，然后他们说，好的，去这个地点看看有没有空位，我看了看，每个小时、每天都有四个空位，所以时代真是变了。我不确定美国是不是这样，但在加拿大，想要预约打疫苗，我记得当时有大概六个浏览器
across two computers and like hitting F5. And I tried writing a script at one point, but it just wasn't. I think we talked about trying to get you to Colorado. Yeah, yeah. That actually, so that was super kind of you. I had- I can't remember what it was, if I tweeted or something came up and I just-
分布在两台电脑上，然后不停按F5。我甚至一度尝试写一个脚本，但就是不行。我想我们之前讨论过想让你去科罗拉多。对，对。那其实，你真是太好了。我有——我记不清是什么了，是我发了推特还是有什么事情发生了，我只是——
Or no, that's what had happened is I was attending one of the virtual- Yes. Previously North Denver C++ meetups. And I had had my first vaccine and was trying to get my second one. But basically the way- I was in some weird postal code, which is the equivalent of a zip code in the States where like I didn't qualify for vaccines. And so every once in a while, this account would tweet, say that we have like 800 spots. If you go to this link now,
或者说，实际情况是我当时在参加一个虚拟的——是的。以前的北丹佛C++聚会。我当时已经打了第一针，正在努力打第二针。但基本上情况是——我在某个奇怪的邮政编码区，相当于美国的邮政编码，我在那里不符合接种疫苗的资格。所以每隔一段时间，这个账号就会发推特说，我们有大概800个名额。如果你现在访问这个链接，
you can get like a sign up, but they'd be gone in like three minutes from the time. Anyways, you had offered, I had said, oh, maybe I should just come down. Cause you were saying at the time they were, you could walk into any sort of Rexall or Walgreens. Yeah, not Rexall here. But yeah, you could walk into basically any drugstore, any pharmacy, anyone that had a pharmacy and just walk up and get a shot at that. No health card or anything. Or I'm not sure. I guess you don't have health cards in Canada or in the States. But like, you don't need to show anything. They'll just like, which one do you want? Is this your second, third? What'd you have before? And that's it. Yeah. And I almost pulled the trigger on that. It's not quite that. So we had, we had all the
你就可以注册，但通常从发布开始三分钟内就会被抢光。不管怎样，你当时提出过，我说过，哦，也许我应该直接过去。因为你当时说你可以走进任何一家Rexall或沃尔格林。对，这里没有Rexall。但是是的，你基本上可以走进任何一家药店、任何一家药局，任何有药房的地方，直接走进去打一针。不需要健康卡或其他什么。或者我不确定。我想加拿大或美国是没有健康卡的。但是，你不需要出示任何东西。他们只会问，你想打哪一种？这是你的第二针还是第三针？之前打过什么？就这样。是的。我当时差点就下定决心了。其实没那么简单。所以我们有你们所有的
backups that you all had, but you know, like a month before you did or something like that. Right. Yeah. And then by the time you were trying to get your second shot, it was now super easy here, but now the vaccines are not quite as free-flowing as they were you do have to make an appointment again and make sure you have a slot and i think it's more just about managing inventory than it is about actual availability like they don't want to defrost a bunch and throw them away or whatever right anyways i guess the moral is everyone should go get their shots uh they definitely and also to a side benefit i was never a big fan of needles i mean still i'm not but there's a couple times now where i've had to get a uh tetanus shot for whatever reason and uh you
后备方案，但你知道的，比你们早了一个月左右。对。是的。然后等你试图去打第二针的时候，这里现在变得超级容易了，但现在疫苗不像以前那样充足了，你必须重新预约，确保有一个名额，我觉得这更多是为了库存管理，而不是实际的供应量问题，比如他们不想解冻一堆然后又扔掉之类的，对吧。无论如何，我想道理就是每个人都应该去打针，它们绝对——还有一个附带的好处，我以前从来不是针头爱好者，我是说现在也不是，但现在有好几次因为各种原因我不得不去打破伤风针，嗯，
know some freezing for dental work and now i'm just like oh yeah like vaccines are great you know like that's just uh the more the merrier you know it's uh i used to sort of be concerned going in and now it's just like i remember that after getting the first vaccine, I was in such a good mood. Like I think I ran I ran a couple of kilometers there and then got the shot and then continue to run, whatever, however many more. And I was just I felt like invincible. I was like, oh, yeah, I got this vaccine. And like some people were saying it knocked them out for a few days. And I was oh, man, it like it was like a booster in terms of my mood. And I felt like I was a superhero because there was just so much anxiety around being able to go out.
你知道的，还有牙科手术的局部麻醉，现在我只是觉得，哦，对啊，疫苗太棒了，你知道的，这就好比，多多益善嘛，你知道的，我以前去打针的时候有点担心，现在就觉得，我记得打完第一针后，我的心情大好。就像我记得我跑了几公里，然后去打了针，接着继续跑，不管又跑了多少公里。我当时觉得自己无敌了。我当时想，哦，耶，我打了这个疫苗。有些人说它让他们好几天起不了床，而我却觉得，天哪，就我的情绪而言，这就像是一个强心剂，我觉得自己像个超级英雄，因为当时对于出门这件事有着太多的焦虑。
And it's just and it was, you know, it's only the first one of two. And you get even more invincible, quote unquote, you know, after the second one. But just I don't know. I had a very good experience. You know, it felt like someone punched me in the shoulder a little bit. But other than that, I was like, all right, I can go take on the world again and, you know, go and hang out in someone's backyard and feel that much less anxious about, you know, ending up ill.
而且，你知道的，这只是两针中的第一针。打完第二针之后，你会觉得自己更加“无敌”了，可以说是这样。但总之，我不知道。我当时的体验非常好。感觉就像有人在我的肩膀上轻轻捶了一拳。除此之外，我当时想，好的，我又可以去征服世界了，你知道的，去别人的后院闲逛，对于生病的担忧也减少了很多。
I kind of had a similar-ish experience on my second shot. You know, it was like 12 hours or whatever before the symptoms hit me from the actual shot. And then I was like knocked out for 12 hours pretty hard but then on the like third morning or the second morning the third day after the second shot i woke up i'm like i felt great and i went on like the best run i had gone on in like a year like i was so bizarre yeah yeah it's uh yeah folks folks haven't gotten their shots you listen to those stories and go get your your superhero superhero status um tune in next week for part
我的第二针经历也差不多。你知道的，从真正打完针到出现症状大约有12个小时。然后我被症状击倒了大约12个小时，感觉挺难受的，但接着在第三天早晨，也就是第二针之后的第二天早上，我醒来时感觉好极了。我出去跑了一年多以来最好的一次步，感觉太奇妙了。对啊，如果你还没去打针，听了这些故事就快去获得你的超级英雄状态吧。请收听下周播出的三部分访谈的第三部分
three of this three-part interview with jason thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与杰森的对话，感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。